it's time once again for our monthly
meetup going over all the free games
we'll be receiving as PlayStation Plus
subscribers for the month of December
2018 there's six this month with three
available on your ps4 like usual you can
download all these games from the first
Tuesday of the month let's crack on with
the headliners the first game of the
month is none other than soma a science
fiction survival horror game first
released back in 2015
soma is played in first-person which
makes scary encounters all the more
frightening there's a fair few jump
scares to survive creatures of all
shapes and sizes some infused with
science fiction tech filled the world
and of course the darkness doesn't help
your heart rate when I played it it
reminded me of Bioshock and dead space
smashed together in an attempt to make
you poop your own pants
but unlike both those games we don't
have the ability to fight in soma this
is all about running for your life
kinda like outlast the game starts with
our hero having a brain scan and waking
up in this world sounds wonderful
doesn't it reviewers loved this game
awarding it eighth and ninth out of 10
noting the story as a strong aspect
gonna try it go on a dare yeah you can
be honest who's too scared to try this
on the flipside of that is our next game
on rush which only released a few months
back this one is brand spanking new as
you can tell this racer is an arcade
racer there are a few areas of
simulation but onrush is solely about
having fun at breakneck speeds vehicular
combat is what keeps the game feeling
fresh with motorbikes rowing cars out of
the road thanks to the power-ups they
gain but my favorite element is watching
the ragdoll physics kick in after taking
down one of those bikers to be awarded
boost we can try our hand at stunts so a
risk reward factor is always present
forcing those behind to train same
tricks to stay close don't think you're
completely alone and on rush as it
allows teams of six to work together
other game modes include a racing
version of good old battle royale where
undoubtedly receiving this game because
it did so poorly in terms of sales but
the reviews all say it's a good arcade
racer definitely worth a download right
over on the ps3 is Sterry den a pixel
art scrolling shooter the soundtrack in
particular is damn impressive but in
terms of mechanics if you play the art
type series you know
what to expect here use power-ups to
take down your enemies and then take
down a boss at the end of each section
rinse repeat nothing to write home about
but if you like that sort of thing
starey Danny's perfect for you next we
have steins gate yet another visual
novel on ps3 I feel like we talked about
these quite a lot this is all about
changing the pasts to create new story
arcs you don't really play steins gate
you experience it as the genre of visual
novel suggests there's a great deal of
reading here but if you pay attention
you'll be rewarded with branching
options to drastically mix up things for
the characters you love and the ones you
hate - okay over to the Vita the first
game which is playable on the ps4
iconoclasts this is a superb little
action platformer with a gorgeous art
style and is another game released this
calendar year gameplay involves fighting
and exploring as you'd expect but the
puzzles really help break up the
repetition and can be challenging in
later game the game puts you in the
mindset of preparing for boss fights and
allows you to practice with a range of
mailing and other weapons in terms of
story your unliveable mechanic named
robin who decides to take on a sinister
religious group why not I suppose sadly
there's not enough review scores to help
us here so we'll have to move on instead
and finally game sticks is a beast
papers please it's such a damn great
game does it involve shooting people no
does it have the greatest graphics ever
no this is gonna be hard to sell but
papers please puts you in the shoes of
an immigrations officer attempting to
decide who can enter the country and who
is sent away it's a game that teaches
empathy and I could not recommend it any
higher you must decide if you will take
a bribe and maybe use that money to help
your family but what if that person who
came in is here for nefarious reasons
and everything is traced back to you
there's so many small heart racing
decisions to make here if you have a
Vita I beg you to play it so there we
have it
eight games for December what do you
think okay I know it's a bad month in
general but keep in mind Sony wants us
buying games around Christmas time so we
tend to receive lesser games at this
time of year but in terms of 2018 as a
whole this has been great for PS Plus
please let me know your thoughts I
imagine from PlayStation granade it's
been a pleasure
I'll see you
time